as professor dasher introduced my name
is kihan
i'm originally from korea but i've been
with in this country for about 10 years
already i came to state forever back in
uh studying hospice business school and
prior to that i've been working for
bcg accenture and i started with my
company back then i guess it was a
mmorpg company i was a game developer of
the company and
after i came to uh states after the
school i worked for google as a product
manager for search and payments and
display advertisement and android where
in android i was heading the entire
google play store opening uh internet
international markets so
for play store i work on the ebooks
magazine and
movies for them for the play store and
then i joined escape player
last august
where
i'm working on product management and
the staff u.s marketing
so
today i
want to talk more about innovation of
innovation in korean market
and how
we as a plan is playing to
let's say adopt or deploy the strategy
of innovation into united states and
looking forward those are the main topic
for today and i'm happy to get any
question
during the presentation so it'll be more
casual
uh presentation moving forward
okay
so first section
i want to talk more about open
innovation in korea
so before i jump
into this slide when i first came here
2004 my first impression about u.s
market us basically is how slow it is
it is means let's say when i try to get
a
phone line to 18t it took almost
one day basically
i have i had to wait for four hours five
hours
in a row just to get a cable connection
and when it comes to internet connection
it was pretty much slow
so in korea so it's just opposite
basically everything is so fast like
delivery from from delivery to service
to even internet connection so fast
so basically
there are so many unique there has been
and there are so many unique products
and service offerings
in korea but
the the basic brownstone was because of
the high-speed network and penetration
of the smartphone in turn is so much
high
and so now smartphone penetration
careers about 70 percent
and when it comes to a speed speed of
network
now i'm using a t
iphone 5
which is connected to sometimes 2 lte
but in korea almost everywhere it's
fully covered by lte now they are
deploying to deploying the st advanced
model
so and then the other interesting fact
about korea is really homogeneous market
where
with really high popular population
density meaning once you deploy one
single product service basically
everyone will be installed will be using
it in five or three months you those
guys are
basically they are impatient so that you
have to create a different service for
them to be satisfied those are the
markets trade
so
so in order to explain the uniqueness of
internet and global industry in korea
i'll just i simply list off a couple of
several products over here
so i don't need to go over every single
product but let's say i can just point
out a couple of things
first there was site work which was
created about 15 years ago it was way
before
myspace and facebook nowadays it's not
really doing well honestly we actually i
managed the company but uh but the the
product the company's not yet not is
doing really great but basically it was
the sort of uh phenomenon of the social
network service back before by myspace
and uh let's say smart wallet over here
which is sort of like a passbook or
google wallet which was maybe created
way before google and apple
we have with which is uh covering like
around 10 to 50 million users out there
meaning users in korea using smart
wallet pay and manage their pay the bill
pay something in the restaurant and
managing their wallet with this simple
thing called a single application
thank you sure
okay
much better
so i can explain the kakao talk
basically it's uh
i know the guy who created this company
whose product
the actually that founder was
the famous found founder of the
han game one of the really famous
schedule game in korea he created this
kakao talk which is similar to whatsapp
basically he simply copy the whatsapp
from the beginning but he came to the
offering
now have 130 million usually out there
and likewise
another libel of cacao in korea is
neighbor they create a line service
which has more than
basically
several hundreds of users all over the
world basically so worldwide systems or
services
and uh
personally explain it so this is mobile
messenger based puzzle game basically
it's like a mechanical struggle but it
was created way before those services
which was tied to kakao talk where
i guess almost everyone in korea
were playing this any pong game
everywhere on the subway
let's say a meeting room dining room
living room etc
so those are the really interesting uh
phenomena in the market
and uh recently i see a really
interesting product service nowadays
which is pedal in job i don't know how
to translate it but basically like it's
delivery service meaning
a merchant like i'm i'm the owner of the
small
let's say pizza house
so i
contract with this guy
they basically promoted my
merchant
so as a user i can search the nearby
restaurant who can deliver pizza from me
right away so with this application all
those smaller media merchants are able
to track their marketing channel
efficiency with that product
so
i know there are some companies out
there here in the united states already
but basically what i'm trying to say is
all those interesting
product services were created or
initiated in korea
even before
we saw we see in the united states and
all these uh let's say
ingredients are were able to support
this
trend
in the u.s market in the career market
so
um i talked about
the sort of phenomena in korea
so i'm going to explain why and
let's say what's the driver to
support
that sort of new trend or new phenomena
in korea
so i believe there are three
buckets or three stakeholders to support
that
trend
first
government and then corporation
and the user and developer but it's more
interestingly um
like the other asian market korea was
driven by government from the beginning
this guy has been really pushing hard to
make something crazy from the beginning
basically
uh some people complain nowadays that
all those things that government has
been doing so far
were useless were ineffective or
inefficient but uh to me
that's not really a true argument
because
actually without having these crazy
investments and the
push push from government
maybe there might be there not be really
interesting phenomena in korea
so for example they create a bunch of
funds using like a collecting fund from
private sector even public sector to
create a team that's something crazy
stuff like deploying entire city entire
country with high speed in the
connection
stuff like that
and they tried to set up the difference
and art of the world all the places all
of the areas
and they initiated a national wide
promotion for their new initiative
because of that
a lot of people in korea
realize acknowledge that there are
something going on in the market so they
are more well educated about the new
trend
and there are many interesting like the
idea forum let's say acceleration from
the beginning there was the drive by
government
and after that because of the influence
from government
some big companies were trying to let's
say put some money
but it was mainly for their growth
basically because they are private
sectors
so for example sk is a my company
basically they create a bunch of measure
service like between
techo and credit card company so even 10
years ago they create a mobile mobile
sort of mobile credit card using your 2g
cell phone they were trying to let's say
create a mobile credit card back then
and telecom companies were trying to
create a healthcare service using sort
of their devices
and there are many uh there are and
driving many incubation services led by
big guy like samsung lg
sk now this nhn which is the number one
portal like google in korea
are initiating those of
incubation services
after having all this
nowadays users developers are
more into this sort of open innovation
they're looking for new opportunity in
this market
so that
there are many several let's say
incubation accelerated program led by
several entrepreneurs i know it's right
quite common in silicon valley but
here in korea it was really a new sort
of trend recently
and then let's say if you go to any
school like a top school in korea like
engineering school a lot of college
graduate even college students are
jumping into startup nowadays rather
than finishing their degree those are
the really
fever the things that show the fever in
the market
so i want to explain more about the how
it has progressed a bit more detail
from government to
cooperation
to a user level
so as i i would just repeat that what i
talked to in the previous slide so
basically the first period
was all driven by government
and they initiated all those technology
and infrastructure innovation
so here are some examples i can show
and the second phase um
basically all about the led by big
corporation big companies
like a samsung or lgsk all those big guy
like a so-called jabber or conglomerate
are were putting their money into the
innovation stuff
and
even back then there was some sort of a
small startup small companies but it was
not really significant effect at that
time
and there were many uh product position
innovation
led by these big companies
nowadays it's more
similar to what's going on in the u.s
market with silicon valley where
we see many new leaders are coming out
of nowhere meaning small startups are
pumping up as a big leader in the market
and still but accessibility leader in
the mobile internet industry are keeping
the momentum as a leader in even in
mobile
so these are examples i showed already
before you leave that slide would you
care to put dates on those periods would
you say
when do you think the transition between
the second period and the the current
period is so
around two to three years basically
really about 2009 2009 ten total sort of
transition inflation point yeah okay the
second place is twelve phases okay
what did you see any kind of a special
thing that makes you think that
special
i don't know concrete events or anything
that are happened around that time that
said ah this means that we've got to
change basically it's quite related to a
mobile adaption
okay so basically smartphone that's in
korea was a little bit late
the reason because
samsung was follower apple was innovator
yeah and then even after iphone was in
came in the us market
sk telecom my uh
the company believed that
apple would not be successful
so that they boycott boycott the airport
yeah i heard that they delayed it by a
couple of years right
so because of this it's been delayed for
a while but the second carrier kt
tried to get the iphone and import into
korea so because of that juice bomb in
the market
right after app ipo came in the degree
market sk partnered with android and
google they
basically support samsung really big and
then right now the penetration android
market in korea is about eighty percent
more than eighty percent basically
so almost everyone in korea are using
smartphone so because of that
actually there's so many startups
pumping up
and now when we see we saw the tons of
new startups around this time every
frame
okay which explains sort of inflation
point yeah
i see many more opportunities for the
users right for the the developers and
so forth right
basically it's quite simple because
quite simply speaking
because everyone in korea are using
smartphone
starting from around 2009 2010
because as a developer you should do
whatever you want
so summary of the section
so
three players three buckets government
and business and developer
because of that
we see a bunch of
innovative and unique product offerings
from the market
and also i see some sort of monetization
opportunity there's some initiative
going on in korea but frankly speaking
between the two buckets i rather believe
they think that this is more advanced
than the monetization area
so
like the in the states
um i
i tend to i kind of believe that the
innovation immunization in korea is not
really
there yet
and uh
since i worked for google for this
display advertisement and some google
play store i know a little bit about the
whole cpmc pc
comparison with among the countries but
basically
other than the united states oldest
market outside in the u.s market is
quite low in terms of cpm cpc ratio
so that still this market not really
heated enough and the innovation in
korean market not really complain yet
so
these are the slides for section one
so i've been talking about
more about korean market
definitely i can answer more about the
quest query market question later
so moving on
i'll
spend some time on the explaining
my what my companies are my companies
look like
so that i can explain how this company
is trying to achieve the sort of open
innovation in korean market and later on
i can explain how it's going to be
deployed in global weapons too
so like professor mentioned earlier
this company is quite unique to me i
joined
in august last year
frankly speaking i did not know this
company before i joined join this
company so i got a call from sk
some of the ac guy back in april
and i know sk telecom but i don't know
much about escape player which is a
subsidiary of the scheduler comments of
now
and then what
the mission for sk
planet is to
cover handle and lead all those mobile
internet services for sk group where we
have digital content
and integrated commerce
and the
marketing communication i can explain
more about it so basically when i say it
is the content we have
mobile digital marketplace like app
store or google play store where we have
we cover games music video all those
stuff that's one portal or we have a
mini particle to support that for
integrated commerce um basically we have
online offline
commerce marketplace so we have sort of
like ebay we have services like ebay we
have an offline online related program
that covers 40 million users out there
meaning with the single plastic card or
mobile card you can
accumulate rarity almost everywhere you
can burn your rarity
and we have some coupons passbook
let's wallet to all those things related
to commerce area
and the marketing communication is like
an agency meaning you can create a
online offline promotion and creative in
with using internal resources
so roughly speaking all those portfolios
generate around 1.5 billion with usd
rabbids revenue
and around 2000 people are employees for
this company
how many employees did you say
um actually it's about 2500. and
when was sk planet started
so yeah sure
escape plenty gospel performance get
telecom back around
october 2011. okay about two years ago
okay
so basically the chairman of the sk
group
and uh the ceo who is my boss
they are sort of founder of the company
because sk has been escaped
teleconstruct you've been trying to go
global try
something crazy on the internet side but
they realize that
sort of dna cultural dna and the way
they work as carrier might not be
correlated in the mobile industry so
they decided to spin off the major
function of major business lines of sk
telecom a separate unit
and from the beginning they were trying
to go global but uh the
reality was
there land that that many employees who
have global experiences
so there have been but still they're
looking for a global initiative yeah
okay
good thank you
so
i want to explain more about what escape
planning provides
more from
let's say open innovation perspective
so when i first um as i mentioned
earlier when i first got a call from
sk actually he was my boss
he i my question to him was what's the
meaning of the escape planet
because plenty to me is like earth
whatever but uh he said the planet means
platinum plus platform plus network
so from his point of view from his
philosophy
we in the worst case scenario in the
very extreme scenario we mean that we
may not become
a destination site
whether we can become a sort of uh
enabler
we can
connect help people to connect each
other something like that so meaning
the mission for this company is
basically to support
openness ecosystem from the beginning so
that's sort of like that's a more likely
philosophy of this company
so i'll explain more about these all
those sub uh opening open innovation or
ecosystem support initiative later
the point is
um not only we are providing like or api
some sort of ecosystem support for
developer like we provide some payment
infrastructure structure we provide
carer building support for all those
players in the market but there are more
than that basically we are putting
real money we are people on those orders
initiative without considering the
p l
because we don't really
it's really critical for us to have a
prop making profit but when it comes to
this ecosystem support
we really pour tons of money to support
ecosystem in korea
and along with this uh
support
we've been quite successful in this
market so this bucket basically shows
that all those top tier products in the
market basically either all these guys
are either number one number two in
korean market
so i just uh simply speaking i just
summarized all those traffic that we are
generating as a summarized summary so
there is a neighbor in korea which is
like google
and the kakao talk is another the
phenomenon a messenger service
those two skyla leader in terms of
traffic but when i just combine all the
traffic we have basically number one
in terms of traffic
so the point is uh
this company even though french speaking
in korea market people do not really
fully people are not briefly aware of
this escape planning brand
they know let's say
okay cashback they know t-store they
know t-map they know 11th street
they donate for sidewalks but they don't
know much about escape plan they don't
know how to associate with each other
but the point is
this company has been quite successful
in terms of deploying the
great products in the market
um as i promised i'll explain more about
the how we support
the openness open ecosystem in korean
market
so to me what is quite tracking
when i first joined this company is t
academy
so
when escape telecom decided to
promote android system
they also started the
local
third party mobile marketplace like this
uh app store or play store it's actually
because i was a leading play store i
know
it compares between the two
marketplace
back then there are there were not that
many developers
so back then there are not too many
developers who know the code how to code
sort of android and java system
so they because of that they create a
some sort of a
pseudo university
where they teach
and train
coding
for those developers anyone can join in
it's free and they provide a sort of
like office facility they provide all
this facility like computer
bandwidths etc
and they provide mentoring from the
beginning to the end
and if when they create a bunch of uh
games or applications
we promote it through t store that was a
sort of strategy just to promote
the ecosystem of the market
and we created open innovation center
center where now they are leading terms
of acceleration program because they
take care of dolores developer
and uh let's say open ecosystem active
initiative for escape players
and the funny thing is we have test
center where
basically we
are able to test entire devices in the
world
when somebody released
some application basically you need to
qa
tune the all those uh devices is better
but in most case you cannot because
there are so many variations especially
in android so we have a facility where
as a developer if you are let's say
uploading some sort of application we
provide separate service for you to take
make a test
on every single devices
these are the test center
so
like this way um the
and the also another example is that we
provide loan
i mean real loan to the developer if
they don't have enough money we give
money
with a really low interest rate for them
to be survive
surviving for a while and we ask and we
give a more chance to be successful in
later stage
so as i said we are really putting some
money
simply really believe that uh making the
pie bigger in korean market will
eventually give us better position
so i know the number of the money we
have spent on this initiative so far is
more than
basically
i guess
10 million 20 million basically it's
really really big money we're spending
tons of money for
just to support and promote this open
ecosystem in the market because i guess
partially because of that the
uh before play store and then kakao took
tied together
history was number one for a while but
nowadays it's not not
really good honestly because the whole
taco token then plays tour syndrome up
there
so
like i said this escape please be
successful in korean market but
like all other korean players there are
always challenges basically the market
is not really
big enough
so some people say let's say if we
launch same product
in the states
we'll get better valuation
easily go to billion level valuation but
if you're launching some something in
korea even though you're so successful
and pioneering there's no chance for you
to become like billion variation
and then the population small and some
sort of limitation
sort of a
model for entire
successful
entrepreneurs and big companies
wanting to go after
beyond green market
there is one sort of
key takeaway as of now
and then the other
conflicting
issue
that we are facing is whether the career
market is really test bad
for the u.s market so
here's my some anecdote i had a chance
to talk to a presidential strategy to
educate the former c of this google
where we'll discuss the asian interest
strategy from such point of view
so what he
what we're debating was whether the
korea japan asia or korea japan and
china are really
sort of a test bed
for the u.s market that what we were
debating was back then was yeah it could
be testing bad just because it's
fast enough but
from his point of view i have never seen
such a really unique and innovative
product except the sidewalk
so i don't believe that career market is
a sort of test bag
i kind of agree because he's a ceo
and also i had no real different
argument to argue back the serious
comment but as of now as i show in the
previous slide
where we use a bunch of a new innovative
unique product offering
i tend to believe that this market is
quite unique and there's a way to let's
say
use this markers test bed
for somebody to get into the u.s market
in the future
so here's sort of explaining
so that
so we're thinking of uh we were in the
from beginning we were thinking of
getting into going into the u.s market
for some reason
so
this is this is from like my sales pit
pitch to many potential let's say
colleagues when i recruit people
here
so unlike other small startups
this guy his company can try something
crazy they're bold enough to try
something new try a
something big problem
and then the things i realized when i
first joined this company because i was
running the t-store and there's some
other content operation
here at escape planet and back at google
i let the whole international of google
play store when it comes to product and
engineering sites definitely google is
way better no doubt
but when it comes business operation
merchandising all those creation data
management
sk plan is better than google
really i i really mean it
and as i said i guess i feel like we can
leverage the
korea is test bed
and
unlike that asian company all those
management here escape plans are all
global exposure exposed
and the u.s market
as we know
the most innovative and biggest market
in the world
and uh i will mention later about a
basically division opportunity we're
thinking here it's quite aligned with
our strategy
and uh
here's a simple step basically overall
track from traffic wise
50 of revenue or traffic are coming from
u.s market in most cases around 20 or 25
are coming from western europe
or of 10 to 15 are coming from the
advanced asian market like china japan
korea
not really india india more traffic more
not from monetization
but the others those are staff but
around 2006
six and five or seven whatever
the notion on industry in the internet
industry was
even though you are successful in u.s
market you cannot you cannot be
successful in asia market because we
have to customize it everything
things are changing i guess since around
2009-10
so
successful products in u.s market
are starting to
pick up
in asia market without
heavy culturalization without heavy
localization
so that's why i guess then the other on
the flip side
it might be easy even easier for the
non-us
player to get into u.s market because
to some extent
global markets more like a homogeneous
moving pool nowadays
so those are the sort of our rational to
get into try to get into use
market so so far i've been talking about
um
korean market basically
and then escape planet
then section three is more about the
strategy
so
it's more company
specific strategy
but i'm happy to get any feedback or
challenges because we're trying to
something crazy and new here
in the future
so
i tried to uh
show
some
lessons and learn we will learn from
many failures
so far
i guess that way i can at least say yeah
here's the sort of mistake we've been
using doing so far we do not want to
repeat the same mistake again
when we want to get into this market so
i believe this is another lesson for
other
players who want to
go global in the future
um like the other small carriers sk
telecom has been really
they have enough cash always
so they've been putting tons of money
like more than billions dollars
into
looking for global opportunities
so i just simply instead of a couple of
things
let's say in the upper hand it's more of
a failure
that costs more than billions probably
these are some sort of some small
success i can explain
so helio is a pro like a mvno
service joint venture between schedule
recommender sprint sprint
and it will fail
of course
and then um
and sign word even though it was it was
so successful in asian market korea
market they were trying to
launch
similar product in the state with the
similar strategies marketing marketing
challenges media product strategy is
fair
so if i sum up all those lessons from
those failures
they simply try to localize their
product
they don't care about us market users
sell simply localize it
string localization simple ui changes
that's it
and then many asian companies when they
get into u.s market
basically they send over tons of ex
expat
from their headquarters
it's not just for korean companies for
china is for japan basically
so and then those guys were hired are
hired in the u.s office
cannot make a decision at all because
they have to go back to headquarters to
get a final approval
and those guys who coming over from
let's say their own
country cannot speak
english
and they don't know much about marquette
at all those are the sort of
common
situations among those asian
players in the united states
it's called the same sk was the same
always
i don't know much i'm not sure whether
you guys know this but uh basically bq
was created by stanford gbs guy
i guess he the the founders are
stanford's gps class of 2006 or seven
which one um vicky okay it's sort of
like youtube with the
subtitle
by community creation created
i know this guy
but basically they created from the
beginning to targeting the us market
they recently accepted and sold this
company to rakuten
around
200 million
so we are the
the largest shareholder of this company
sort of like success story
wider than.com is more way before but
basically it's a bring back service
and then the founder of this company is
my ceo
and who his company was
listed in
nafta
and sort to real networks
such as scenario but basically
um whenever i talk to somebody who knows
k this first impression was sk has been
failure all the time
because they've been putting tons of
money into your smart cap
more than billion
so here so i will simply summarize
these lessons
then actually these lessons i'm trying i
always deliver this lesson to my
team member in the usa office
we should have authority on this john
here rather than
in the headquarter
and we have to work with the people from
this market not from the
the oversea market
and we have to target u.s customers from
the beginning
and there could there should be some
sort of edgy or some resources we can
leverage it so whenever i spoke to speak
to some potential partners candidate
here the first question was
why
sk should do this
what's the what's the reason behind for
you guys to try so there should be some
sort of rational to support
your strategy and patience because
um
i'm not sure that i mentioned this but
basically korea is really impatient
so
that's really really crazy in patients
the reason why samsung was so successful
because they had to change the model
every six months
because kids are changing their summer
smartphone every six months
what is going on in korea so
we should be more patient
so
having said that i will
simply
explain the strategy of this company so
basically we're
spending most of our resources on the
commerce area when i say commerce it's
not like ebay or amazon it's more likely
mobile to online offline commerce
probably like a shopkick or a shopla or
a square like those are the system where
with your mobile
device
we want to help users to purchase
something
either in the big store or small store
without friction those are the sort of
like
vision
and then this can lead to a marketing
activity so basically you're trying to
benefit the merchant
as well as the consumer
and we've been trying out the digital
content earlier
initially we thought about uh deploying
like google like like google play store
we want to deploy t-store here in the
united states but i don't think that's
not right strategy because without
having a
opening system there's no easy way to
distribute your content over the
smartphone so for this content basically
we're targeting some small in each area
like game
where education
where we can expect to have quality
content cross traffic
which eventually leads to this commerce
area that's our hope and we're trying to
find some sort of uh
overlapped area between content and
commerce area
and definitely we should create a bunch
of enabling monitoring platforms that
support this they need these two pillars
in the future
the reason why we put together strategy
in this way
basically as i mentioned earlier
at least in korea we have
all sorts of value chains we have all
the components in value chain in this in
this area
and then the real problem of
in the united states because is nobody
has seen the proof
of how it works
in the real world
so one way is we can try some craziest
investment
on product engineering and then business
side and we want to leverage queer
market as testbed to show how it works
in the real world
there's a high level strategy
and that i will just simply go through
but basically the whole area is a mobile
convert mobile traffic to online
commerce so
i'm going to learn we'll be we'll be
launching one product in early
november
where
it's like a star fashion creation
product meaning
when let's say i'm a normal user i take
a picture of miranda kerr celebrity
we're wearing like a channel handbag i
want to buy it but actually i don't know
whether it's a channel or goody i just
simply take a picture i unload it and i
can
using some advanced mechanism tagging
system
we as companies provide a rear the same
item or similar items on the application
so that you can purchase it right away
this
you can purchase channel but you can
purchase some similar item which is
cheaper item
normally i guess you prefer cheaper
right so you can purchase
the similar items in somewhere in the
merchant side either online offline this
is the sort of like that's the product
we are working on
mobile to offline basically i guess
there are many things are going on like
apple announced that i become people and
also sort of paper become
brutus ble nfc
and now we're deploying nfc to entire
merchant in korea at the same time we
are looking thinking of
deploying ble sort of
things in korea and united states as
well and
combining all those data we have we're
trying to do something crazy as well
here in the united states
so traffic generation we are targeting
we are preparing launching two products
targeting more gdc which is game
developer center sort of conference in
later in the la in february or this
march time frame
basically there are two products one is
that we're trying to match up all those
activities popular in
mobile like
chatting plus
conquest and chat and beating
fighting mm-hmm rpgs there's one area
the other thing is so like a
social we call it as play for me meaning
when you are stuck into level 2125 and
you can use country soccer i cannot play
i can i don't know how to crush the
level
i can pay
of course i can pay some money but i can
ask my friend to play for me
so simply putting the button it goes to
you who is better than me
and play the game for me and then
there's some social element inside the
game those are the games we're working
on it will be deployed to sdk where you
could multiply as a single product so
those are the areas we're working on
nowadays
and definitely we are looking for
organic meaning we want to build product
from the scratch so
we've been i've been hiring around 30
people in soma in san francisco
mostly coming from google
facebook airbnb like pearson engineer
cody and agree those are guys coming and
joining working in here at the same time
we're working we're thinking of putting
some money to acquire companies
around
800 to 800 million to one billion budget
we're thinking of investing some
companies out here
that's the plan
so
since this topic for this presentation
is more about open innovation
i was thinking of how we
can come up with this scenario for
innovation for us entry strategy
so definitely this company is trying to
build a product leveraging like a
business operation know how
asset resources in korea for u.s market
at the same time we are building will be
building products
not only from scratch but also acquiring
the companies over here
and
i believe there are many opportunities
opportunities for us to become
a
bridging
the gap between korea and asia and u.s
market
so one example
i i'm heavily participating in some
accelerator program
led by
so key startup so one of my friends
worked we worked together at google
who's leading a set of stuff he is a
leading whole acceleration program
and we see uh tons of big
funds french capital
really pretty big entrepreneurs are
really interested in the asian market so
they want to find some great companies
from asia
pick up and move to united states
likewise they
pick up great products in states
can't move over to korea and asia market
but the connection the bridging the gap
between the two continents
it's not really easy so we were trying
to provide that sort of uh service
service means like funding like facility
providers mentoring business operation
etc those are the other initiatives we
are thinking of
uh putting some more resources like as
we did for korean market earlier but the
way we
let's contribute
to united states should be much
different because back then in korea was
not like the u.s u.s at this time
so simple summary
basically
all these are the things we been uh
supporting
in korea market
the point is we are
based with this uh sort of ground base
will be uh
creating something
new and unique
value proposition
when we
let's say try to contribute to the
openness open information ecosystem in
the united states moving forward
so recently we opened the
office in the summer around may time
frame
as we grow and further and more we
definitely will be putting in the
spending or investing more resources on
this openness supporting the open
ecosystem or this
society
that's the plan
so
i guess i cover most of the slide
right
and uh just simple wrap up i just simply
summarize what happens what i've been
picking so far
first
i believe there were there are
uniqueness and you know innovation in
korea
you know internet mobile industry for
sure
and uh
the interesting interest interesting
thing is that government has been
driving from the beginning but later
now it's driven by
individual users as small companies like
in silicon valley
and i strongly believe that escape
planet had a pivotal role in creating
sort of momentum from the beginning in
korean market
and
like the other companies in korea we
were trying to go global here
and we have many challenges but uh
definitely that's my mission to overcome
those challenges
so these are the whole summary
so i guess this is it so i'm happy to
get any question from the audiences
first of all thank you very much
so let me ask one of the first questions
it seems to me that when you're thinking
of open innovation
kind of your classic model is the
app developed app developer community
right especially for mobile apps
do you think that they really have a
chance to grow or would they essentially
be acquired by a larger firm within a
few years how do you see that
no more application right yeah
i guess
frankly speaking to my knowledge my
acknowledgement yeah analogy
both in korea united states um i guess
the main goal for
app developers
are to be acquired by by big companies
in reality
because
i haven't seen such a um
there are some phenomenal ipo right we
remember all those ipos but in reality
most of the companies
are targeting small niche market
on top of uh existing big players
yeah area right for social
except uh let's say facebook
all those social guys are trying to
target from each area
around social market area right
like a search i haven't seen any other
players ever since google yeah
and i guess only player and uh i guess
about three or four years ago
most of bench captor
were trying to pour some money on
vertical category commerce
so now it's got bought by amazon most of
them yeah
and uh
i guess the only things were
not bought by the big guy
were like a messaging services yeah but
except mostly
yeah
but right now i think the acquisition
market for startup companies in korea is
difficult right but yes it has been
always difficult
so unlike silicon valley where a big
company like google facebook they set
the budget to acquire some companies so
for example the way the reason why
googlebot weighs
around 1.3 billion valuation actually
it's crazy
but uh because there's some sort of a
standard in the market yeah but in korea
it's not it's not going to happen at all
meaning the valuation is that or
understood
one thing
even the uh acquiring
some sort of companies in korea is not
really
yeah sort of a standard it kind of looks
to me like sk planet might be
positioning yourself to be a leader in
doing more acquisitions so we acquire a
couple of companies yeah basically but
well
actually it was never successful
but that's okay because that's the
fundamental of the acquiring because the
portfolio is important so sk
i guess probably uh tried we've been
spending uh
100 billions yeah on the quoting and
then sort of investing
into some company yeah
but unlike us others more big players in
the market like nh and um sort of portal
player
not really a
companies in the market yeah that's why
small players in korea are trying to see
opportunity outside korea because there
are more
eminent opportunities yeah you you uh
you telescoped my next question which is
about uh developers in korea
entrepreneurs in korea bringing things
to the us to develop in this market do
you think that's
a pattern you see or
well i guess it's not a pattern it's
more likely
inevitable
okay pass for the sky of course there
are opportunities inside korea yeah but
uh here's some some cap
in terms of valuation in terms of market
size right okay and still debating
internally internally means like not
just me and my colleagues more of an
intern market
some guys say
you should first uh so show some
presence in korea then
go then go overseas overseas someone
said just go
but in reality all those developer
engineers in korea do not know how to
speak english they don't know much about
how to even live
here in the silicon valley so there are
many a sort of gap in between the
scenarios okay but sk planet could be a
provider of enabling services for this
the academy and that destination
for us okay yeah got it
let's open the floor
do you have
organic growth or do you have any case
like spinning how is the
so in korea
have we ever bought a company
maybe not not quite
maybe the staff company they are working
on something but they need resources you
have all the resources there
in your umbrella and
bringing down
so recently we sold the company
to a private kodi guy
so we have we used to managing melon
which is number one
sort of music streaming service like
itunes in korea we sold it to uh
hong kong-based private equity company
because i believe that the company is
really great but they're hitting the
market cap
so that we're looking for not looking
for any more on the industry anymore
and the other example
was
vicky i explained it later earlier
we originally thought about that
getting into the
video market is quite critical that's
what we get the signific significant
share of the the company but later on we
realized that may not the register so we
sold the equity to other guys recently i
set up the
company
inside us organization where they are
working on some social messaging service
which is frankly
so we are still uh
exploring some idea of spinning off
getting a setting of the
company company style of company inside
escape planning
okay good
thanks for
an interesting talk
the example you gave about
taking a picture of
a person with a purse and then
recognizing what it is are you using ocr
and then
who are the merchants how is that
working so ocr in most cases now really
providing the high quality
so even for the text-based ocr
basically if there's certain irregular
pattern you cannot recognize that so
there's always some human labor
involvement so i don't really believe it
i used to work on translation at google
but no never works
so for this type of service we not we're
not using ocr whether we ask them users
to tag
the items
but the way we can differentiate it is
to
enhance the
database of structure
so for a single item we provide nine
depths of database nine depth category
but we don't have to show surfaces to
user but by selecting one single tag tag
basically we narrowed down all those
possibilities so if you select less
female
then jacket
later then you see
only a couple of trades left
because we support it behind the scene
the
more sophisticated database and by using
by
let's say creating more data
where let's say training the algorithm
not to create a stupid
selection recommendation
you're working with they're
giving you access to their databases to
do those dips yeah so as of now since we
are not providing the money transaction
we are basically acquiring content by
putting some money
i guess the uh if i want a small startup
where i have only 100k i cannot do it
but since we are backed by big capital
from the beginning i will use the
capital as more likely seeding
content seeding once you get a collect
content i will put some payments
function so that people do not may not
need to leave
the application
and with the money from affliction
partner we give the money to
content provider or seller to sort of
ecosystem
you mentioned that
the transition from
big cooperation driving innovation to
developers driving innovation happened
because of the growth of the mobile
industry and it sounds like most of the
innovation in korea right now is focused
on
the mobile space and internet space
so how do you see the next area of
innovation coming into being is it going
to be do you have to repeat the whole
cycle having a government driving first
or do you think
a big corporation like sk plan would
look for the next area so
simply just if i were
to have started my own company
i'd rather work on
either two one two things one
monetization on mobile or enterprise
i'd rather do it
and
the way to innovate
in those area
i guess
either you have
some crazy
idea what strategy or technology where
you have tons of money
that's my view
it helps even to be both right right
there's no way to get the post but
basically
the reason i'm saying that the twitter
is quite important because
so far the way we let's say do business
in mobile internet industry
is simply to create a bunch of traffic
without considering all this money
anymore
right but all this valuation i see
nowadays just
just because basically you
don't really you cannot expect that once
whatever one billion billion valuation
from simply to one billion traffic right
so the point is
as of now in the first mobile industry
where users have more engagement
with the devices
meaning on the web you have some purpose
and intention when you see web on mobile
you don't have such intention anymore
basically it's a sort of a spontaneous
engagement
and we are putting putting tons of
irrelevant advertisement
and people hate people hate about it so
there should be some smart way to
monetize traffic on mobile that's why we
are i'm thinking of putting some money
on the
internet
in sort of a commerce area
that's one thing
and enterprise different thing but the
point the backer question um i quite
don't think that the government will
drive the animation anymore
because it's sort of uh
the innovation i'm thinking in the
future is more on the on top of the
existing platform rather than that's
really more of a macroeconomic
phenomenon than that than it is
a particular industry evolution right
okay
a quick follow-up question you're
talking about mobile to online or mobile
to commerce and also mobile to offline
how's the divide in korea between
traditional retail industries that are
primarily offline department stores and
supermarkets and whatever versus the
online community are you starting to see
the offline
uh retail outlets doing more online
promotions and so forth
well
as a merchant
basically the money i'm putting pouring
onto the promotion
it's basically uh
garbage
to some extent because they don't know
how to measure the
efficiency or effectiveness of the money
their system budget
but basically spend the money because
they tend to believe you'll be working
so there are i mean offline materials
are putting some money on the online
channel just expect to get more customer
retention through the channel but still
they don't know how to measure
the value of that money investment yeah
and the other aspect is
when i look at this whole step basically
the inner internet
equals penetration on return side
so ceiling is about 25 percent
as of now the highest penetration in the
world in commerce is but is around 15
which is korea and united states 10 to
15 years our heist
to up to 25 we can expect to grow the
sort of
e-commerce area so point is
there should be some smart way to
measure the efficiency of their
promotion budget
both for online
online is quite simple but especially
for offline yeah
i i guess that's the really critical
thing that's why paper spends tons of
money on falling on the investment unp
paper beacon apple
square i guess those are the areas
okay
you had a comment i saw your name you've
established a successful method and
process for business development in
korea but as you target the united
states market what are the risks and
challenges that will present themselves
and how will you change the method as
you penetrate this market
so when i uh
look at the stat basically all your
startup in the valley
the chances of being successful it's
about one percent one percent means like
either acquired ipo all together right
when i look at the portfolios of excel
partners like anderson horowitz kpcb
it's around ten percent even those
really big bench capital are ten percent
so when somebody asked me a question
whether i'll be successful i have to say
between one to ten percent basically
so the only thing i can do
better
is to leverage some sort of uh
operation resources we have
in korea
and then more importantly um the
know-how
on the commerce side
which cannot be recopied from the
technology guy
so
now your answer though sounds like your
primary measure for growth is going to
be your venture capital investment here
no no no no okay no okay so we're not
we're in a financial ambassador okay
with some budget we're trying to put the
money for more strategic purpose even
though we are acquiring company it
should be aligned with my strategy
so back to your question basically i
guess technology product ux we should
get
those things from here but when it comes
to commerce sort of uh know how
i guess i may be able to leverage to
know how we have accumulating so far
in the market and also
since it's it takes tons of money to
deploy those strategies here in the
states
we may may need to
test it out
in korea first to see if working it
could be really a reference point for
all those participants in states even
right
thank you i saw several hands
bevin you go first
where the funding of sk
come from
okay
it's
a
i have never seen the money honestly
but some of somebody in the finance said
we have around 800 million
and then definitely i i'm looking for
excellent investors like privately who
can give us equity financing for the
financing
and we are generating
some amount of
free cash flow every year so with that i
guess there's some money but the point
is it's not really money it's more of
opportunity meaning i don't still don't
know how where i should spend that much
money
there's more
question i should probably point out
that you know this sk group looks as a
business group that you find you find
groups of companies like this in korea
and in japan
and uh you know so telecom was the
sort of the central company in the group
about how many companies are there in
the sk group now would you say
i don't know
yeah the only thing i know is sk group
is about
the revenue is about 150
billion or total
including like oil gas semiconductor
carriers extra so but that's not the
money i can spend i expect a certain
certain portion of the money
so i i mentioned that because a new
company like sk planet
will uh essentially be created to
serve as a new business
and
it will be very interesting to see what
the group's expectations for sk planet
are
right yeah i see
well awesome
it's still early right it's totally
created in 2011 so right yeah so
yeah doing dance clubs
go ahead please
well
there's some special jargon in this
company they are using as is and to be
when they say 2b is more likely future
business model
when somebody say 2b here at
sk
it means you have three year plan
for escape planet only we have five year
plan
when somebody when i say 2b plan for
escape planning is more five year plan
meaning for five years
i may not be touched by
the big guys
up in the air
but who knows but the point is
they believe that the
going after looking for
opportunity outside korea quite critical
to sk
in general
and they as i showed earlier they've
been
failing
many times they know the lessons
at least they can from their um
mind
they know what is what is right or is
not right
but in reality it's always true but
just like money talks so therefore
whoever paid more money in your group
but have the power to make a decision
right so your communications from u.s to
careers are really very difficult then
come to the big one to make really
difficult take a long time are you
certification basically
um
all those money
board board objective level there on
your poor guy
me my ceo and toddler guy
and all those christians on the us side
i make
because i'm the whole chief producer
entire company so that's what i make
here is the final decision so we know
the situation
because
like there's a small and companies from
other camp and getting getting to u.s
united states where they feel the same
difficulty so we try to minimize all the
hassle communicating between here and
there
and the money wise basically it's not
really from the big guy we are getting
money from the
let's say outside sk
okay
go ahead
oh thank you for your interesting
presentation uh my question is about
product innovation resource
in open innovation will focus on user
focus on a user resource
what's different from you a u.s user to
a clear user
so basically the question is difference
between u.s user and korean user in
terms of ucg et cetera as an innovation
well
simply from ux ux perspective using
interface perspective
users united states are more more
preferred simplistic simple
interaction
whereas in korea in asia they prefer
more on the more dynamic
iterative more complicated
interaction
so i uh hired two
and designer
for one product we test it out
but basically the design
the us guy created was much simpler and
the other ones much more complicated
everyone in korea prefer this everyone
in the us prefer this
so there's some differentiation it's not
really visual it's not really icon
emoticon it's more about the structure
even structure you guys prefer more
simple design
other than that i think that's a very
interesting statement because
user experience design would always say
that you would try to optimize the
operations so that a person could
actually interact with the application
more efficiently
well but the simple principle saying or
always like if you add one more page on
your application
for one page you lose thirty percent of
users it's simple but the point is the
intel's delicate the sort of complexity
of the design
most of the
people in korea prefer more more
sophisticated more delicate design
but here state in the state it's nearly
true so to some people in korea when we
present the product from the united
states they say
it's nothing
it's empty
they say feedback from those users in
korea
i think we're about out of time